シュッッシュッッシュッッシュッッ
シュッッシュッッシュッッ
シュシュシュッシュッシュッッ
シュッツシュッシュクォ
プシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュシュクヮァ！！！！！！！！
強くなりてぇ...
俺は強くなりてぇ！
(箱を開ける音）
キタァ！！！！
商品名
ヘッドバンド付きボクシングエクササイズボールボクシングファイトボール
（袋を投げる音）
ああっ
これだぁ...
あのぉ...ありそうでなかった
商品ランキング
ベスト13位ぐらいだと思います。
こうやっぱ、やっぱケンカ強くなるときってやっぱ
肘軽とか腕のパンチ力も大事だと思うんですけどなにより
相手の技にあたらなければ
一番無敵だと思うんですよ。
結局このパンチを被弾...食らっちゃうから
痛っ......負けで...
ってなっちゃうんで、
もう逆にどんだけパンチが弱くても
相手のパンチを
全部かわして
自分のパンチを確実にね、
どんなに弱くても当てていけば、確実に勝利がつかめる
ってことを僕は知ってしまったんですよ。
パンチさえよければいいんだなって思いまして、
またこんな誰だよこんなの考えた人は！
ひとめぼれして買ってしまいました。
頭にこう、バンドを着けて
こんなに長いものなのか...
（ボールが壁に当たる音）
こんなに長いものなの...え、ちょっと短めだよね。
なんかひもがちょっと長すぎてこれだと
こんなリーチの長い敵はいないと思うので
ちょっと切ってみましょうか。
（糸を切る音）...痛っ！
よし出来た！どうでしょうこれくらいの長さでたぶん頭につけたら
ちょうどいい対戦相手感は出るかと思います。
シャァ！
本当にこれ大丈夫か...？
これでこの玉投げると
ヒュッぼてぼて（球を投げて頭に当たる）
待って、待って、違う何かが目に入った。
イテぇ、痛ぇ（泣）！！！今全然関係ないじゃんだって！
これどうやって特訓すんだよ（怒）！もうちょっと短めにします。
ブチ！（糸を切る音）
どうでしょうこれぐらいの長さだったらちょうど敵にいそうな感じっすよね...
なんでこれで玉投げると！
ヒュッぼて（球を投げて頭に当たる）
アアッ！待ってこれ危なくね？オッヶオッヶわかったわかったァッ
おまえがそこまで言うんだったらそういうトレーニング器具なんだろうなァ！
ボールは全く痛くないんですけど、
ただただひもが痛いです。
いいだろう、それも含めてのトレーニングなんだろぉ？
いやぁってやるよぉぉぉ！！！！！！！！
キュキュキュン
えー、これネタグッズかなぁ。なんか俺怪しい気がしてきたんだけど。
でもちゃんとねぇ、同じような使い方してるんすよなんかメーカーみたいな人が。
ピー！（笛）これでたぶん基本的な使い方はあってると思うんすよ。
（ボールの音）
ヒュッ！危なっ！
ドンッ...アァ！アァ！アァ！危ない危ない危ない！！！
キーンあ、待って痛(ry
もっと普通にやらせて...
（ボール音）ドンドン(スカスカ）ドンドボテドン
アァ、アァ！！！
ドン、アァ、ドゴッ
アァァァァ痛ァァァァァ！！！！！！！！
ドン、アァ、アァ、顎がぁぁぁぁ！！！
ドン、うぅ、はぁ、はぁ、はぁ、はぁ！
ドン、ドン、ウ痛ァァァァァ！！！！！！！！
確実に動体視力が上がってきてる気がします
これね敵の動きがやっぱり速いもんですから、
こういう速い動き
ウェェェェェェェ！！！！！！！
敵はやっぱ動きが速いんで、
こういう速い動きに対してしっかりとパンチを当てていく練習が必要なんだと思います。
ペチペチペチ
ヒュ、アレェ！？
シュッシュッシュッシュッシュッシュッシュッ
アァ、アァ、危な！！！
ドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドン
（音）
シュッシュッシュッシュッアァアァアァアァドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンキタァアァァァァァ！！！！！ドンドンドンドンドンドンドン来てる来てるアレェとれちゃった
ドンドンドンドンチーン
ドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドンドン
アァッアァッアァッアァッアァッ目がぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
目がぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
はぁ、はぁ、目がぁぁ！！、目がぁぁ！！、目がぁぁ！！
アァ、
目が
マック（メガマックｗ）食いてぇなぁ、メガマック食いてぇなぁ
テレレテーレーレ、レテーッテッテ、
で・で・で・でん☆